الى الخبر العاجل الذي يظهر على شاشتنا
الان ا يقول مراسل الجزيره او ينقل لنا
مراسل الجزيره ان عدد الشهداء جراء قصف
اسرائيلي امام مستشفى الهلال الاحمر في
خان يونس ارتفع الى 11د ع شهيدا معنا من
مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل الجزيره
وائل الدحدوح للاضاءه على هذا الخبر
العاجل
[موسيقى]
وائل
الموضوع يتعلق محمود باستهداف لاحد
المنازل المتاخمه تماما لمستشفى الهلاال
لمستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهال الاحمر
الفلسطيني في مدينه خانيونس وهذا
الاستهداف جاء من قبل الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي وواضح ان المنزل استهدف بعدد
من الصواريخ الامر الذي ادى الى تدمير
المنزل وانتشال حتى الان اكثر من 11 شهيدا
ومن المرجح حسب المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه
وشهود العيان بان هذه القائمه سوف ترتفع
باعتبار اولا ان عمليات الانتشال ما تزال
مستمره ثانيا ان الاصابات التي وصلت الى
هنا محمود كانت اصابات صعبه للغايه وهناك
اشلاء وهناك جثامين محترقه وهناك اصابات
بليغه جدا وحرجه جدا وهذا يعطي ربما مؤشرا
ان عدد الشهداء جراء هذا الاستهداف سوف
يكون اك اكبر من ذلك بكثير الى جانب ان
الطائرات المسيره
الاسرائيليه كما قال شهود العيان قد ساهمت
في هذا الاعتداء بشكل مباشر وفي محيط
المنطقه وحسب بيان لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني قالت بان هذا القصف لا يبعد سوى
10 امتار عن المستشفى وان مسيرات
اسرائيليه ساهمت في عمليات اطلاق نار
باتجاه مواطنين فلسطينيين في هذه المنطقه
وهو الامر الذي نحن في مستشفى او مجمع
ناصر الطبي استمعنا الى اصوات الطلقات
الناريه التي اطلقت من المسيرات
الاسرائيليه وكان ذلك قريب جدا باعتبار ان
مستشفى الامل اي ومقر الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني لا يبعد كثيرا عن مجمع ناصر
الطبي وهو الامر الذي كما قلنا هذا ليس
الاستهداف الاول في
محيط يعني مستشفى الامل وجمعيه الهلال هي
في الايام الاخيره محيط هذا المست
المستشفى استهدف بقصف مدفعي بشكل واضح
واستهدف ايضا بغارات اسرائيليه استهدفت
منازل لمواطنين فلسطينيين في هذه المنطقه
الامر الذي ادى الى سقوط اعداد كبيره من
الشهداء والجرحى وفي ذلك كما يعتبر كما
يعتبر المسؤولون في هذه الجمعيه ان هناك
ما يبدو وكانه مخطط لاستهداف هذه المستشفى
قياسا بالتجارب الس سابقه التي استهدفت
على سبيل المثال مستشفى القدس التابع
للجمعيه في مدينه غزه ومعروف القصه التي
حصلت مع هذا المستشفى من حصار واستهداف
وتدمير ومن ثم ترحيل وافراغ هذا المستشفى
اليوم يشتد او تتصاعد وتيره القصف
والاستهداف بالقرب من هذا المستشفى تماما
كما هو مستشفى او مجمع ناصر الطبي ونحن
محمود خلال الايام الماضيه تحديدا خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه بتنا نرصد ربما
مخططا جديدا او مؤشرات جديده في تصعيد
وتيره القصف الاسرائيلي لا سما المدفعي
الذي يستهدف بشكل عشوائي واحيانا مركز على
مناطق متفرقه من مدينه غز مدينه خانيونس
في قلب المدينه والاجزاء المحيطه بمستشفى
ناصر ومستشفى الامل وايضا الاجزاء الغربيه
من هذه المدينه وهو الامر الذي يؤدي دي
الى سقوط شهداء وجرحى في غالبيه الاحيان
لا يستطيع طواقم الاسعاف الوصول اليهم
اصلا باعتبار ان هذا القصف يعتبر من اخطر
انواع القصف وباعتبار الاستهدافات
المستمره والمتكرره بحق طواقم الاسعاف
ورجال الدفاع المدني حتى الموظفين في
مصلحه المياه او مصلحه بلديات الساحل وكل
هذا الامر بالتاكيد يضفي اجواء او اضفى
اجواء غايه في الخطوره غايه في الصعوبه
وهناك عراقيل كبيره جدا فيما يتعلق باداء
هؤلاء لمهامهم سواء رجال الاسعاف او رجال
الدفاع المدني او الموظفون في بلدي في
البلديات او حتى في بلديات مصلحه بلديات
الساحل كل هذا الامر بالتاكيد
يضفي يعني او يعمق الماساه الانسانيه على
ا حال اليوم كان هناك عده استهدافات القصف
المدفعي على اشده وهذا هذا الامر ياتي
جنبا الى جنب مع تحذيرات من قبل جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لعدد من المربعات
السكنيه في قلب منطقه خانيونس الى جانب
مربعات في منطقه الوسطى تحديدا مخيم
البريج مخيم المغازي واجزاء من منطقه
النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه ب يامرهم بالنزوح
باتجاه الجنوب وهذا يعني ان جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يريد تجميع الناس في مربع لا
يتجاوز
يعني عشرات الالاف من الدومات في منطقه
رفح على وجه الخصوص الى الى جانب شريح ضيق
من منطقه المواصي في محافظه خانيونس وهذا
خطير جدا على اعتبار ان معظم الناس الان
يتكدسون في هذا المربع بطبيعه الحال
باستثناء المتواجدين في منطقه شمال غزه
والتي تتكون من مدينه غزه ومحافظه الشمال
لكن على ايه حال هذا الامر ناجم عن سلسله
استهدافات بالقصف الجوي الاسرائيلي والتي
ما زالت مستمره وايضا تكثيف سياسه القصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي والتي ادت قبل يومين
الى مجزره في منطقه المغازي والبريج راح
ضحيتها عشرات من الشهداء واعداد كبيره من
الجرحى وتدمير عدد من المنازل وهذه
السياسه ما زالت مستمره على العكس هناك
تصاعد في وتيره ونسق هذه السياسه
الاسرائيليه من القصف المدفعي و عليه فهذا
الامر بالتاكيد يعني هو الوجه وجه من
الصوره الوجه الاخر بالتاكيد يتعلق
بالعمليه البريه العمليه البريه بالتاكيد
هناك اشتباكات نحن ما زلنا نستمع الى
اصوات الانفجارات لا ادري ما اذا ما كنتم
تستمعون اليها وهذا ناجم عن القصف المدفعي
فضلا عن الاشتباكات الدائره بين عناصر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تحديدا في منطقه خانيونس واكثر
تحديدا في الشمال الشرقي شكرا جزيلا لك
وائل الدحدوح